all it takes is an iconic dance sequence
or a fantastic line read to turn a
no-name actor into the next big thing
some of your favorite actors can trace
their successes back to a single
Unforgettable scene
Mike Nichols 1967 classic The Graduate
captured the general malays and
middle-class American Youth in the 1960s
in this adaptation of Charles Webb's
1963 novel of the same name Dustin
Hoffman stars as recent graduate
Benjamin Braddock who feels
directionless and isolated after
returning home to Pasadena as Benjamin
settles into the army of his personal
Crossroads he finds himself
propositioned by Mrs Robinson an older
married friend of the family which sets
the film's story into motion this is
Robinson you're trying to seduce me
[Music]
tryouts are starring in the graduates
Hoffman primarily worked in television
and on stage but the film's critical and
box office success made him one of the
most acclaimed and recognizable actors
of the Year Hoffman was nominated for
best actor at the Oscars for his role as
Benjamin and he went on to have a
high-profile movie career Mrs Robinson's
seduction would go on to become one of
the more recognizable scenes from the
movie and one of the most iconic scenes
of all time for that matter
Rocky Balboa at Cinema's most iconic
boxer the protagonist of a successful
film franchise has spanned from 1976 to
2006 and evolved into the acclaimed
Creed spin-off series just as Rocky
Balboa was given a million to one shot
to rise from a South Philadelphia nobody
to becoming a boxing Superstar the
franchise gave Sylvester Stallone his
big break too as the sole screenwriter
for the original film one of Stallone's
stipulations and selling the script to
Studios was that he would Star as the
movie's titular character salone's
gamble paid off with the young actor
portraying the amateur boxer who battles
heavyweight champion Apollo Creed for
the championship title and Glory while
Rocky is full of memorable scenes
perhaps the most unforgettable is the
Montage of the grueling training regimen
that Rocky undergoes to prepare for the
fight this scene culminates with Rocky
running through Philadelphia at dawn
triumphantly racing up the stairs of the
Philadelphia Museum of Arts as a soaring
theme song Gonna Fly now place it's an
iconic moment that gets echoed
throughout the franchise's sequels and
despite become an indelible pass of both
Stallone's career and pop culture as a
whole
Star Wars completely turned the film
industry on his head spawning a
multi-billion dollar franchise and
countless genre imitators since the
original film premiered in 1977. while
the core Narrative of the movie focuses
on the coming-of-age story of young Jedi
Luke Skywalker the original trilogy's
King of Cool is none other than The
Smuggler Han Solo portrayed by Harrison
Ford solo made his memorable debut in a
CD Cantina negotiating support from Luke
before blowing away a pursuing Bounty
Hunter
[Music]
prior to his turn in Star Wars Ford
Works primarily as a carpenter while
also having small supporting roles in TV
shows and the movie American Graffiti
Ford's introduction as Han Solo exuded
his unique brand of self-assured cool he
perfectly embodied the ultimate
mercenary with the Heart of Gold who has
no qualms about shooting first while
Ford would have followed his first
portrayal of Han Solo with a long line
of popular roles including Indiana Jones
it was his first appearance in Star Wars
A New Hope that first solidified his
status as a minted movie star
by 1977 disco music of all the nightlife
in many major American locales like New
York City and Los Angeles that's why it
made sense that the movies Saturday
Night Fever would explore the cultural
impact of disco fever and bring it to
the mainstream the movie stars John
Travolta as Tony a disillusioned
Brooklyn teenager who finds purpose and
catharsis by dancing at disco Tex on the
weekend at the time Travolta was best
known for a supporting role in the 1976
horror movie Carrie as well as his
starring turn on the popular sitcom
welcome back cutter as Tony Travolta
channeled the frustrations of urban
youth in the post-vietnam war malaise
into a beautiful dramatic performance
that nabbed him a nomination for best
actor and the 1978 Academy Awards
Travolta's most iconic moments in the
film shows him confidently walking into
his favorite nightclub in a sharp suit
and embarking on a thrilling dance
number on the light-up floor the
sequence made Travolta an international
movie star and helped Propel disco music
to even further height thanks to the
movies massively pop we love BG's LED
soundtrack
there are very few actors who can
completely embody a previously
established role to make it totally
their own and there are fewer roles that
have as much fun expectation as Superman
despite being a relative newcomer in
Hollywood Christopher Reeve earned
widespread critical Acclaim for his
debut as the Man of Steel in 1978
Superman the movie Reeve proved how much
he was born to play the iconic Superhero
by flying through Metropolis saving his
co-worker friend and eventual lover Lois
Lane from harm after training for years
to earn his powers inside the Fortress
of Solitude Clark Kent emerges and gets
the job alongside Lois the metropolis's
news agency The Daily Planet when Lois's
news helicopter crashes while departing
from the skyscraper Clark makes his
grand entrance a Superman to save her
from falling out of the aircraft easy
Miss I've got you you've got me
who's got you Reeves natural Charisma as
a superhero not only charms Lois and the
people of metropolis but also audiences
around the world to make him a Bonafide
movie star
three years before Tom Cruise first took
flight in Top Gun the young actor
solidified his Ascent to Hollywood
stardom in the 1983 team comedy Risky
Business portraying ambitious Chicago
high schooler Joel Goodson who plans to
get into some Mischief while his parents
are away Crews danced his way into the
public eye during a memorable sequence
set to the Bob Seger song Old Time Rock
and Roll sliding into frame and a shirt
and underwear Joel's impromedu song and
dance moments hero did an even more wild
and crazy weekend to come Cruiser's
dance and portrayal of Joel enjoying his
time alone captures some adolescent wish
fulfillment before veering into some
risque Fair as its title suggests it's
youthful and joyful exuberance clearly
struck a chord in audiences old-time
rock and roll has been recognized by the
American Film Institute as one of the
top movie songs of all time modocina
itself has been referenced and parodied
in all sorts of places from Love
Actually to Scrubs Cruiser since become
one of the most bankable movie stars in
Hollywood and Risky Business gave his
career the jump start it needed to
ascend the list
although Bruce Willis ended up being one
of the biggest action stars of the 1990s
he was primarily working as a television
actor in the preceding decade after some
bit parts and supporting roles Willis
got his first Big Break by starring on
the popular television series
Moonlighting which premiered in 1985. of
course Willis's star turn in 1988's
action flake Die Hard was his career
defining role which turned him into a
full-on action hero and kicked open the
door for him to transition fully to the
big screen in Die Hard Willis stars as
police officer John McLean who's
visiting is estranged wife at an office
Christmas party in a Los Angeles
skyscraper things go awry when
terrorists take over the skyscraper to
try to steal money from its Vault and is
up to Mclean to jump in and save the day
while Willis has plenty of fun favorite
moments in the original die hard one of
the most enduring is him proclaiming a
vulgarized Twist on Roy Rogers
catchphrase
the catchphrase would be echoed by
Willis in a line of Die Hard sequels
while his performance as McLean
catapulted him from television screens
to Cinemas worldwide
Ridley Scott's Thelma and Louise pad of
Gina Davis and Susan Sarandon as the
titular best friends who travel together
across the American southwest to take a
break from their oppressive day-to-day
lives however the quick weekend getaway
turns into an impromptu cross-country
Odyssey as the women find themselves on
the wrong side of the law after a man
tries to assault one of them the pair Go
On The Run meeting a number of
interesting characters along the way one
of them is a young Brad Pitt who plays a
Charming amateur Thief JD Thelma and
Louise capitalizes on Pitt's natural
Charisma by having JD seduce Thelma in a
particularly memorable scene in which he
flaunts his muscular body while wearing
a cowboy hat not surprisingly Pitt's
performance immediately turned him into
an international heartthrob although the
actor managed to challenge that image by
turning to more serious roles in the
years I followed however for all the
academy award-winning success Pitt has
since enjoyed it was this playful turn
as a handsome Thief that first put him
in the spotlight
filmmaker and night shyamalamus
catapulted into the Hollywood mainstream
after the success of his 1999
Hurricane's drama The Sixth Sense the
supernatural Thriller follows a child
psychologist as he works with a young
boy with the ability to see ghosts but
as he tries to find out what's really
going on with the mysterious child he
discovers some dark truths about himself
Bruce Willis plays psychologist Malcolm
Crowe and the role of his patient Carl
Sia is portrayed by Haley Joel Osmond
with the latter's vulnerability fueling
the movie's paranormal premise one of
Osmond's most memorable moments in the
film is when he tells Malcolm his big
secret four words from the young actor
would end up making him one of the most
recognizable faces in Hollywood after
the film's release
I see dead people
people while other up-and-coming actors
like Michael Sarah auditioned for the
parts of coal it's hard to imagine
anyone but Osmonds on the role he
definitely balances childhood innocence
with the supernatural Terror permeating
throughout the movie and brings a
surprising depth of emotion to the
otherwise frightening film since the
Sixth Sense Osmond has enjoyed a steady
flow of roles in television film and
video games while inter is adulthood but
since 1999 performance as a boy who sees
ghosts remains his most iconic to date
the wachowski's science fiction film The
Matrix became an instant classic and
cultural phenomenon when it was released
in 1999 thanks to its trippy narrative
and visual effects showcase to set the
reality bending Stakes for the franchise
the film's opening sequence shows
Freedom Fighter Trinity battle her way
through police forces before escaping
from Relentless agents in an epic
rooftop chase at the center of this
action set piece as actor Carrie and
Maas who literally kicks off the movie
with a dazzling slo-mo martial arts
strike Trinity's iconic let's audiences
know exactly what kind of Advance via
effects they were in for It's Gone on to
be parodied and referenced by everything
from Shrek to scary movie The Master
would only really appeared on television
and lower budget films before this first
entrance as Trinity brought her
significantly more prominent roles and
the chance to repriseable of its sci-fi
character throughout the Matrix
franchise
while Austrian actor Christoph Walsh had
worked steadily on stage and in
television in Europe for years his major
Splash with North American audiences was
with the 2009 film in glorious bastards
In This World War II film written and
directed by Quentin Tarantino the bolts
portrays the cunning SS officer Hans
Lander a man committed to mercilessly
hunting down Jews hiding from the Nazis
Vault says deliciously evil performance
and undeniable Charisma in such a
twisted role are in full display right
from the opening sequence of Inglorious
Bastards in which we see exactly how
Lander has earned his fearsome
reputation playing out as its own
chapter in the film the opening of
Inglorious Bastards begins with Lander
visiting the home of a French Dairy
Farmer whom Lander knows to be harboring
a Jewish Family in the scene of chilling
psychological warfare Lander charms a
farmer before suddenly turning icy and
cruel getting the man to reveal his
secret before massacring the sheltered
family the scene boasts at the tone for
Inglorious Bastards and turned vaults
into a Bonafide star in the states not
surprise surprisingly volta's
performance as Lander earned him the
Academy Award for best supporting actor
in 2010.
that's a bingo
[Music]